since the announcement that Jared Leto
was going to be appearing as Morpheus in
an upcoming Sony film movie fans across
the world have been asking the same
question who the heck is Morbius the
short answer is that he's a vampire
whose curse comes science rather than
magic who operates sometimes as a
villain sometimes as a hero and often a
bit of both
beyond that simple concept though is a
complicated character a tormented soul
seeking salvation and blood here's the
untold truth of Morbius the living
vampire blood sucking fiend
Morbius tends to be a good guy by
default these days but when he first
showed up in 1971 s amazing spider-man
number 101
he was tragic and he was tormented but
there was no antihero nonsense going on
Morbius was a killer that issue was
memorable for a few reasons most notably
being that it was the first issue of the
comic that wasn't written by Stan Lee
Roy Thomas took over writing duties
picking up on the cliffhanger ending
where Peter Parker had six arms
spider-man sought out the Nobel Prize
winning dr. Michael Morbius in hopes
that he could find a cure but instead
found a blood sucking vampire who looked
like he raided the Bee Gees wardrobe
Thomas considered Morbius to be a
one-shot enemy for spider-man but he
also knew there was more to him than
just simple super villainy as he said in
a 2009 interview both sides of him were
always there he was always supposed to
be a fairly sympathetic character
Morbius versus the code the comics code
was a self-imposed industry standard
that among other things banned all
representations of the undead starting
in 1954 some fans believed that Morbius
was referred to as a living vampire as a
sneaky way of getting around the comics
code and that his subsequent popularity
helped break it down for good his living
status was Marvel's loophole or so the
legend told the truth is that his
creation was actually a response to the
comics code having already loosened its
rules about vampires zombies and other
undead creatures since they were no
longer restricted under the codes old
rules Thomas and Lee considered using
the most famous vampire of all and
making Dracula the villain in amazing
spider-man number 101
instead Lee opted for a twist on the
classic vampire as a costume
supervillain
although Marvel would launch tomb of
Dracula the following year giving the
original blood sucking Count a series
that ran for 70 issues ironically while
Morbius his creation didn't create any
friction with the comics code an
another Marvel artist claimed to have
locked horns with the coat over his work
on the character years later penciler
Ron Wagner worked on the first 14 issues
of Morbius the living vampire and in
1993 he told wizard magazine he got in
trouble with the code for sexually
explicit drawings in the comic operative
word living while Morbius is living
Status wasn't meant to sneak around the
comics code it was an important aspect
of his character if for no other reason
than the fact that it allowed him to
remain in the Marvel Universe far longer
than his undead contemporaries in 1983's
Doctor Strange number 62 the sorcerer
supreme famously used his magic to boost
a magic spell called the Montes II
formula killing Dracula along with every
other vampire on earth eventually
Dracula would make his return coming
back from the dead is just what that
dude does but it would take a full
decade in the meantime one vampire
remained completely unaffected by any of
it our man Morbius because his condition
had nothing to do with being bitten by
some seductive undead temptress or
stabbing a church doctor Strange's war
on Dracula had no impact on Morbius
other than the fact that he probably had
a lot more food available considering
all the competition was dust to infect
or not to infect over the past few
hundred years people have defined
vampirism pretty thoroughly
especially after Bram Stoker gave us all
the blueprint in 1897
Morbius on the other hand is all over
the place including the question of
whether his bites can create other
vampires even when he drinks someone's
blood they only become vampires like
sometimes the first character he ever
transformed was Jefferson Bolton Marvel
team-up number three unlike traditional
vampire spawn bolt retained his free
will and intelligence eventually turning
on Morbius more often than not however
the living vampires victims either die
from the normal injuries you'd expect
from having your neck snacked on or
survive them with the usual mundane
consequences whether or not his
abilities allow him to infect others has
less to do with his condition and way
more to do with what's convenient for
the story a little help from my XI Hulk
one of the most important stories in
Morbius is history the tale that
transformed him from a tragic villain
into a dark hero involved a weirdly
violent court scene in the pages of
savage she-hulk temporarily cured of his
pseudo vampire condition dr. Morbius was
working on
to help another character with an
interesting blood related problem lawyer
Jennifer Walters who's gamma-powered
blood transfusion from her cousin Bruce
Banner turned her into the she-hulk
while helping her Morbius was arrested
and when Walters defended him during the
trial
she used a bizarre method to protect her
client to prove Morbius was not in
control of his actions while he was a
vampire Walters brought a pair of
rabbits into the court and fed one of
them the formula that had transformed
him predictably the rabbit immediately
went full Holy Grail and killed its
furry mate Walter's succeeded in getting
Morbius as charges reduced but the
public wasn't happy right after the jury
read its decision her father told her he
was ashamed of her which might be even
more painful than what happened to that
poor rabbit story versus gory when
Morbius got his first shot at a solo
title in 1992 it began with the creative
team of Lynn Kaminsky and Ron Wagner in
spite of the passion Kaminski felt for
the project his time on the title was
short-lived the reason apparently he
wrote too much story speaking to back
issue magazine in 2009 Kaminski
described Morbius as one of his dream
projects and said that he'd plotted 50
issues of the series when he started
including a crossover with spider-man
and venom
unfortunately he was fired from the book
after only eight issues Kaminsky
recalled that he wasn't sure why editor
Bobby chase fired him but in a 1993
wizard article Ron Wagner said that he
was tired of Kaminski's character-driven
stories that he wanted more action and
more gore in the chase agreed when
wizard reached out to Kaminsky for
comment the writer said Wagner used to
leave snide notes in the margins of
Kaminsky scripts and that he tried to
call Wagner to talk over changes but
never got a response
once chase fired Kaminsky colorist
Gregory Wright gave Wagner the goryeo
scripts he wanted or a little while
Wagner himself was gone from the book by
number 14 ultimate Morbius when jared
leto brings Morbius to the big screen
there's a chance he won't be a living
vampire at all ultimate spider-man
number 95 introduced an updated version
of Morbius who had a much bigger
connection to the vampires of his world
than the regular Marvel Universe's
version he was a more traditional undead
vampire who told spider-man he was the
son of Dracula and spent his time
hunting his brethren and operating as a
villain
while Marvel officially put the nail in
the ultimate lines coffin in 2015 its
impact on the film adaptations can't be
ignored a lot of what we've seen in the
MCU was first seen in the Ultimate
Comics Nick Fury was first drawn as
samuel l.jackson in the ultimate six
years before the actor appeared as the
shield director an Iron Man Black Widow
and Hawkeye being a part of the original
Avengers lineup
Captain America's world war ii era
uniform the invading alien soldiers from
the first Avengers film and plenty of
other visual elements seen in the movies
were lifted from the ultimate line
there's no reason to believe the Morbius
filmmakers wouldn't learn from the MCU s
example and draw on a much less
complicated version of the character
Morbius vs. blade or not while he never
actually made it to the screen for a
film adaptation letõs casting isn't the
first time that Morbius has had a brush
with Hollywood in fact if screenwriter
David Gore's original plan had been
realized the living vampires first big
screen appearance would likely have
predated the MCU by eight years the DVD
for 1998's Blade written by Goya
features a deleted scene in which a
mysterious figure in a dark trenchcoat
watches from a nearby rooftop as blade
and Charon emerge triumphant from their
conflict with lamare in 2016 David Goyer
confirmed the figure was intended to be
Morbius and had he gone on to direct
blade to Morbius would have been the
villain for the sequel instead Guillermo
del Toro directed Blade 2 and the story
was altered to Pitt blade against the
Reapers instead by the time Goya
directed blade Trinity the focus had
shifted to Hannibal king and the
spin-off ready night stalkers all three
movies wound up featuring stone cold
evil bad guys which makes sense since we
all want to see blade chop their heads
off but presenting a more tragic and
sympathetic foe could have made for a
very different very interesting movie
[Music]